all right guys
bang bang uh lee is here and we are
going to
talk about all kinds of awesome things
so thank you so much for uh for doing
this
thanks for having me absolutely um for
those that don't know you maybe let's
just start with your background
and kind of uh where you grew up and
what you did before you got into
journalism oh well i was very young
before i got into journalism
i grew up in boston i was born in boston
and i grew up in a little town
south on the south shore called norwell
um
and yeah just a small town upbringing
and i probably wouldn't have
really been very cultured or worldly or
interested in intellectual things except
i was so focused on reading as a child
and for me reading was an escape you
know i was definitely that like
quintessential child who like
was really introverted my mom always had
to be like
go outside and play and talk to people
and i was always very
you know i just felt books were so much
more interesting than people
and now i know that's not true but it
took me years to get out of my shell
and now i tell people i'm a fake
extrovert a lot of people think i'm a
natural expert and i am not
um in fact just doing this not on the
phone and on cameras
you know just so not me but uh
you know there was this opportunity to
talk more deeply so i thought
why not um so i grew up yeah mostly just
in love with books and reading and
writing and
went to journalism school and when i
graduated i went straight to new york
i was lucky enough to get to write for
the wall street journal and
for dow jones and um but i really spent
all of college
like with my eye on that i didn't just
i didn't know anyone in journalism i
come from one of those windy irish
german families
where everyone thinks they can write but
almost all of them
including you know me when i started was
just horrible at it
you know and so you know over time you
get better
and i really like hit my start in
college and then i was very lucky
you know if you work at the wall street
journal or you're lucky enough to work
in a place where they're these amazing
pros
you get some of the best training in the
world and when i joined the newsroom i
was the only
non-iv person that i knew in my own
newsroom
almost everyone had lived in multiple
countries spoke multiple languages
you know so i was very lucky to be
coming
into a place that was just where there
was no way i wasn't going to benefit and
learn
and and that was sort of my early days
so wall street really for the first 15
years of my career
and then as i wrote about corruption as
we led up to the financial
crisis i got much more interested in how
corruption
not just in finance but in many places
it's very organic
your people don't get together and say
hey let's be super corrupt
like let's lie and cheat and steal
because we love it
you know most people end up on a
slippery slope
where it happens and there's a community
surrounding it that's either enabling it
or at some point you're making so much
money that you just keep
going um and i started to realize that
corruption was really
not appreciated and not really written
about very well and
i really wanted to talk to people who
were in those circles and find out more
about how it all worked
um and so i got much more involved in
talking at first to traders but over
time every kind of person
imaginable and really the key is to not
be
judgmental you know what you really want
to hear is someone's real story
you know you don't want you want the
real story and the best story
and the deepest story and so that has
been
sort of my guide throughout my career
and then
from the journal i went on to write for
a lot of other places you know fortune
forbes financial times
um and you saw my institutional investor
story and called me
absolutely and so before we get into um
the the fun stuff around crypto and some
of the work that you're doing now
um you wrote this book and uh this book
on
kind of a world's oil market and uh um
having a deep understanding of the oil
market uh was probably helpful earlier
this year
when uh some of the futures contracts
went negative uh but maybe tell us a
little bit just about where did the
the impetus for the first book come from
um and uh
and especially the title the asylum um
and kind of the thought process behind
that and the work that you did to write
that book
yeah well when i was covering the oil
market on wall street
this was obviously when we had the
second big war
in iraq you know we saw oil prices going
up
and then the new york mercantile
exchange which at the time
wasn't mostly electronic it was mostly
open outcry with traders who were
physically
in new york um you know in a very locked
room all day long
arguing over prices and setting the
global oil prices for not just
not just oil but gasoline heating oil
propane
and natural gas which was always
considered like the big table at the
casino that's where you
had the biggest price swings and could
often make the most money
and i started to get to know the traders
i started to get to know the market
and one day i was sitting with one of
the former chairmen
of the new york mercantile exchange we
were having lunch
and he said i'm so glad that you're
writing about us now
there used to be another journalist for
the wall street journal he used to
always
cover us and at the end of every story
he would always talk about how he
defaulted on the potato market in 1976
and i was like what do you mean potato
you're the oil market and he said no no
first we were potatoes and before that
we were eggs cheese and butter and
you know and i got much more interested
in the history i was still quite young i
was still like you know really my
mid-20s
you know sitting there in my you know
badly put together outfits and the rest
of it and you know listening to this old
chairman telling me about
potato default um which is a whole other
story and so fascinating
but basically this was a market full of
these very down at the heel
people a lot of them immigrants who came
to america
and and weren't getting jobs on wall
street but wanted to trade
and in many cases ended up at the new
york mercantile exchange trying to
scrape something together
and for many years they succeeded but
mostly failed
until a man named michael marks um
conceived of
an energy market and introduced the
first energy contracts
um and he's still alive today he's he's
in new jersey
where he's retired and enjoying the good
life but he
um he was also a wonderful source and i
just got very involved in
the story of this exchange and also the
shenanigans that would go on behind
closed doors
you know whenever i showed up at the
exchange he had a photo of me behind the
desk
um and it didn't matter and you know for
a while i came with a natural
dark wig and maybe i got in twice
but you know i was not allowed on the
trading floor like my name was
everywhere behind the desk it was like
sorry we can't let you in because you're
really a good man and
you're going to want to talk to everyone
so i
i ended up writing the book you know
through the interviews with these
traders and it's really an
oral history of the energy market going
way back to
early last century um to the present day
and just what happened
you know and all that you know a lot of
the greed really did take it over
but just like in bitcoin and lots of
other markets the initial intention was
quite pure and so where did the name the
asylum come from
what was that a uh aligned to sorry i
forgot that part
um the asylum was uh the traders used to
joke about how they were the inmates
and that this was the asylum and there's
a i think
in the early part of the book you should
see it in the first couple chapters at
the quote you know where they talk about
themselves as inmates
um and how how they called it the ascent
so the first time i went down there they
said welcome to the asylum
and i that just stuck with me but it
really was an asylum for them you know a
lot of them didn't fit in anywhere else
yeah that's an awesome story um and then
from there uh you end up writing um one
of the early pieces uh on bitcoin like
you mentioned
um and uh at this point you're at
newsweek tell us a little bit about
uh that story and kind of the search for
satoshi yeah so when newsweek relaunched
um and i was i was i think one of the
first writers they hired and
i just i grew up reading newsweek and
loved it so
i was extremely game to help with the
relaunch um
we had already been writing a lot of
articles online but this was the big
relaunch of print
and one of my editors i've never told
this story but one of my editors sent me
an email
he was a playful british guy still a
wonderful dear friend
and one of my favorite editors he was a
real hard ass you know he
he he didn't give you an inch but once
you proved yourself he
you know he was great and he sent me a
note and said
i've been looking at this bitcoin and
this was around
2013 he sent me a note because i've been
looking at this bitcoin
and um would you look into these bitcoin
women
and i wrote back and said bitcoin women
and he wrote
well i don't know but that bitcoin is
trouble and wherever there's trouble
there's women
yeah there's a lot of sexist jokes in
the newsroom it's just part of the life
um so i thought oh yeah let me go check
it out
but i the more i looked at it the more i
realized this is phenomenal
and and how would somebody even begin to
create a code that could could act as
currency
and somehow get the rest of the world to
actually exchange cash for it
um you know imagine yourself going into
a room with your smartest friends and
saying
hey how about y'all give me some cash
for this code that i'm running
you know they'd laugh you out of the
room um even if you were brilliant
right so my big question was how did it
really get off the ground
who was behind it um there seemed to be
some people who knew more things than
others
and it was not um it was not a bad thing
that
gavin anderson who was the chief
scientist at the time
uh he lived just a couple towns over
from my home in vermont
so it was easy to pop over there and
just try to get a lay of the land from
him to start with and really i just
wanted to
talk to you it was early days it was it
still hadn't exploded yet
and you could still go and talk to like
the top 10 people who had
emailed with satoshi right you know who
had
talked to him a lot and had very strong
opinions on who this person was
and my first thought was let's create a
profile based on what all these people
say and agree on
and then take it from there um to see
what we can find in the world
that fits what they've directly
experienced
yeah and and i think that you know still
to this day people
ask the question you know who is it
right and uh there's some people who
believe
it's better off that nobody knows and
there's other people who believe you
know it would be awesome to figure it
out
um and uh and in this in the story um
obviously dorian uh nakamoto who uh
i've i've met and uh we've hung out at a
uh at a conference
um and couldn't be a sweeter guy um is
now become kind of a uh
i don't want to say a staple of the
crypto community but but he is
definitely uh present
um quite often which is uh which is cool
to see him
uh kind of attending events and things
like that as well what did jordan say to
you when you talk to
i'm interested uh i'm not trying to
interview you but yeah
so i actually don't remember kind of the
initial conversations one of these
things where like you you don't remember
exactly what people say you just
remember kind of how you felt
um in the initial moments and when we
saw each other we both kind of like lit
up
and uh and went over to each other we
were talking
and i think he was probably just as
surprised that i recognized him as i was
that he recognized me
and so it's kind of this weird you know
like oh okay um
and uh it was in la at a uh at the
bitcoin 2020 conference
and uh or i'm sorry san francisco uh and
uh
and we were hanging out and he just was
like
happy to be there and like you could
tell he was excited about
kind of all of the energy and everything
that was going on
right and and people were coming to talk
to him and all this kind of stuff and uh
i
just i think that was like my biggest
takeaway was just happy
like he was very happy as a person um
which uh you know
is somewhat rare in today's world so
when you see somebody like that i think
uh you kind of remember it yeah
he i mean he's an incredibly i mean his
whole family who i interviewed
very very brilliant guy and um
he's not some old guy he's not a random
old guy
he's very brilliant and he um you know
he
he's you know he's into it obviously you
know he's quite enthusiastic even today
um and you know i think that uh
even though i haven't been able to talk
to him directly you know obviously in
the
in the aftermath of the story it was
clear
he you know we wanted to do a follow-up
interview so we could also square what
he had said to us with what he was
saying later
and not to get ahead of ourselves but um
but i really
really wanted to be able to connect with
him but it was clear that that wasn't
something he would want to do and
you know you can force situations
journalists you can just show up and
keep trying
you have to walk away if they say no but
i just felt like considering what
everyone had been through in 2014 with
that story
it just seemed better to wait or you
know
to really to wait or at least for the
moment to
let things go and let him settle after
everything
i definitely didn't expect the level
that that went to on the day it was
published well and so
um you know for everyone listening uh
lee and i talked before and like
this is all still i think very sensitive
because there's just so many people
involved in the story and everyone's got
kind of their own perspectives
and opinions so uh maybe from your
perspective
uh because it's impossible for you to
kind of talk to other people's
perspective
um just kind of talk a little bit about
like the quote-unquote aftermath right
so you publish this story
uh it's a cover story and then
you know all hell breaks loose basically
good and uh you know maybe not so good
but kind of what was your perspective
and kind of how do you view it today
i think and i should talk a little bit
about the lead up because that was
important as well
um you know meetup and aftermath
in the lead up we were really just
looking to
get the best profile possible and then
look at every single candidate
several things that the people i
interviewed told me
you know including gavin but a lot of
others who had corresponded with satoshi
and worked on the code
had said things like you know gave
timelines things like uh
the code took about two years to write
according to saturday you know there
were consistent messages that came from
everyone
and you could look at someone's resume
and see you know i remember nick sabo
was a very prominent
candidate for a lot of people and um
but he clearly wasn't free to do what it
was
that those who spoke with satoshi said
had to be done to create the code
uh his itinerary did not match at all
like a very busy person and didn't match
this whole like
spending two years very quietly working
on this thing
um and gavin and the others said that it
was really clear that the code
might have been supplemented by some
people but was really clearly coming
mainly from one individual um
and so a lot of the early pieces of
information and then
certain things like i don't know if you
guys all know this but there was that
you know there was a crashed file when
they were
test driving uh bitcoin before the
official launch and they were just
trying
to get it going there was a crash file
with hal finney
um that had um at one point satoshi had
written to helen said send me
send me the data so i can figure out
what went wrong and he was supposed to
send
it privately to satoshi but instead hal
posted it publicly
on a forum so everyone could look at it
and that had an ip address in it that
led us
to the same neighborhood dorian lives in
in la and so there were certain like
hard pieces of evidence that
led us repeatedly to dorian
but it wasn't um it wasn't something
where
one could say before interviewing him
oh well that's open and show we don't
even need to talk to him like of course
i had to go talk to him
um and there were weeks of us exchanging
emails
i even sent him a letter with a bit card
in it like
that gavin had given me um and so like
when i did interview him he
he had already received all this and
knew that what we were talking about was
bitcoin so i think one of the things
that was most disappointing to me was in
the aftermath of saying
like he didn't know that that's what
we're talking about he definitely knew
that
we were talking about it we had been
talking about it for weeks before i
actually
physically visited him but he really
didn't want to talk about it
you know he really didn't want to
discuss it and i suspect
if there hadn't been two other people
there kind of pressuring him to talk
when i was doing the interview in person
um that he may not have said anything
but by the time the story was published
we had interviewed the whole family we
had interviewed a lot of people
surrounding him we'd interviewed him
um and we'd also double and triple
checked that interview
uh and talked to his brothers and you
know so by the time it came out i
i couldn't have checked anything more
deeply than i had i pretty much
obsessively checked everything
that being said i expected a reaction
because
as you noted lots of people don't want
to know who it is
they consider it inappropriate
there's all those reasons so you're only
even going to be interested in this
if you already want to know if you don't
want to know you're not even going to be
interested in this story
um when it was published
i was ready for a lot of screaming over
we shouldn't talk about who this is what
i was not ready for
was people saying that a concrete
interview
with witnesses never really happened or
didn't really happen the way that
was reported when you worked for 20
years in interviews and no one's ever
said anything like that before he
you know really takes you by surprise so
that day
the storming of dorian's lawn and the
people camping out
and you know just the haranguing and you
know that was
horrible to watch as a journalist it's
the opposite of what you want
um did you not want to see that happen
and i mean i have very wealthy hedge
fund managers who are scared when just
one person comes to their house and
protest with a sign you know like
somebody was telling me the other day
daniel loeb had someone outside
screaming about inequality and he was
like oh it's so upsetting
they're coming to our houses and and uh
i i
you know i can't imagine what that was
like for him it was certainly
uh horrible to watch for me so i can
only imagine what it was like for him to
experience
and then of course everyone's outraged
about that
so you know it was almost like this
cascading
set of events that were in motion that
none of us could stop at that point
yeah and i think one of the things that
um is so interesting as i've talked to
you about kind of
the story and the process and then
obviously the the kind of aftermath
is uh i don't think a lot of people
understand the work that you did
uh before the article was actually
published right so in terms of talking
to the family and like you said kind of
double and triple checking
um and then on top of that obviously
there's people at newsweek who are
looking at this
when you kind of look back at that
process um you know
what do you remember kind of the the
family's reactions or or family and
friends as you were talking about before
the story came out was this something
that was like uh
oh yeah of course you know that's
possible or was
were people kind of completely oblivious
and didn't even understand
you know kind of bitcoin or anything
about it
so jorian and his dorian is the oldest
of three brothers
um and he he changed his name from
satoshi nakamoto to dorian prentiss
um durian apprentice satoshi nakamoto in
1973
and when he became a naturalized citizen
and
he and his brothers are all all very
bright um
his brother arthur they both work for
hughes aircraft
doing classified work um there was quite
a background
his brother had a pipe bomb planted in
his car
and obviously very terrifying when he
worked for hughes
and as a result you know the family felt
really uneasy about any sort of public
stuff
especially after uh you know what
happened when arthur
had that happened to him was you know a
pretty big you know probe into well
did he do it did someone else do it i
guess it was in the professional parking
garage or he was working
so there was already this feeling of we
don't really want to expose ourselves
to things um this this horrible thing
had happened and
um i remember dorian's former wife
telling me
that it was just really devastating and
scary and
you know who would want to put a bomb
you know in his car
and um i think they were very surprised
when people tried to look into him like
he might have put it there himself
it was just upsetting to say the least
and so you know there was kind of a
family feeling of
not wanting to expose themselves any way
to any
kinds of deeper inquiries but
dorian himself was very private you know
when he first started emailing me
back his emails didn't have his name on
it his email said mountain spring
that was it that was his name um
and i thought for a guy who is
you know of a certain age um a
programmer but someone who's also been a
teacher and has done a lot of other
things
um i just didn't i didn't expect i
i might expect that from like a
millennial
but mound in spring from a senior
citizen was quite surprising
so he you know his family had talked
about him as very
private um that he was always working on
things but didn't really share
um and that they did think that he
he could have been involved but that he
wouldn't confirm it
um they all did talk to him uh to to
this day
family members have come to me saying
that they think
that he did but or you know that he was
certainly working on it but that they
can't get him to open up
that so it's really one of those strange
family things
you know i don't know if you've ever
talked to families at length especially
in my case as a journalist you end up
hearing about all the things you know
and then you're like okay
almost none of this is reportable and
it's not relevant
but i do want to give a fair
understanding of who this person is and
what they're like
and um i think the person you see at the
conferences
is a very different kind of person than
person you know that they
experience um but that doesn't mean
those two people aren't real right a lot
of us
we're all complex and hopefully somewhat
integrated so
that was their response um it was kind
of painful too
for some of them um before the story
came out i had to contact
everyone to close down their facebook
accounts or to remove anything that was
going to be publicly not stuff that they
would want to share with the world you
know there were a couple things
one of the kids to put on his facebook
page i thought might make him feel
vulnerable
if everybody was reading it the next day
so we talked about that
there was a whole process of let's clear
out anything that's going to make you
feel
harmed um and so there was a preparation
before the story was released
you know you do what you can as a
journalist you you know we also didn't
want to affect the bitcoin price
you know you have to try to create the
most neutral footprint you can
and that was important in fact when i
reread the story i'm
some somewhat surprised these days of
how kind of simple it is
you know like there was so much detail
we didn't put in
because bitcoin was such a weird thing
to even explain to people so we're just
trying to make it as easy to understand
as possible
the problems that arose with the story
and the protests were so different than
what i had anticipated
you know um questions about certain
parts of the interviews and
if i'd known right i probably would have
written it very differently
it's so fascinating too because uh it
sounds like
you were um you had done the work and
you were very
uh cognizant of the fact that like look
there could be
you know some uh some interest in this
um
spending a lot of time with the family i
don't know how many journalists think
that they're going to basically get
scrutinized by
you know millions of people on the
internet for their interviews and the
way that they wrote their story and like
that's
i think uh not exactly the thing that
uh most journalists go through on a
daily basis um and when you say
aftermath
uh you know that's a pretty good i think
uh description of the reaction from uh
from the crowd if you will yeah and
there was like a hunt
like one of my former colleagues from
the journal called me and said
you didn't really talk talk to this guy
at this classified government
there was a classified government
contracted company that dorian had
worked for
and he said well i talked to the man
that you quoted and he says he has no
recollection of the conversation
and i said well you know okay i guess
we're like gonna look at every single
detail but i can tell you the day we
spoke i can show you the phone records
like i'm happy to do that i mean if
you're really going to say that
maybe it wasn't true then of course i'm
happy to share all that
but i told him being honest with you
barking up a very useless tree
um i know that there's like a protest
going on but
everything here was checked like 8 000
ways till friday
so you know if somebody wants to see
something i'm happy to show it to them
um and and the journalist was like oh
okay all right
you know my bad and kind of backed off
but a lot of journalists wrote stories
and never called me
you know used my name and you know but
never just
part of being a journalist you have to
talk to everybody or try to talk to
everybody here talking about your story
so i felt like there was a lot of that
but i think these days
none of that surprises us right we've
all seen a lot of that lately
and i think for me in terms of the
reaction the saddest part
is when you deal with a complex topic
what you're trying to do is take
chaos and impose some semblance of order
you know take what is a lot of mythology
and
and replace it with facts and
i think sadly a lot of these stories end
up adding to the mythology
in the end because the debate ends up
going on and on and on
and doesn't really end and so that
feeling of i want to break through all
this mythology with concrete facts
you know it was high it was repelled so
hard
that you know you're like even if i can
prove these things
it sounds like no one wants to know or
no one wants to hear it so
that's a different kind of story and
it's a much more intimidating kind of
story when you want to
bring back but there are people who
don't want to know
those facts yeah and before we move on
from this topic
what's kind of your take now on um
satoshi uh and the importance i guess of
finding out who is satoshi
for bitcoin um and kind of the bitcoin
community
like do you think that is important and
then any thoughts in terms of
dorian somebody else no clue like
how do you just think about satoshi in
general now
so i think it is important i think it's
still important to know
especially as we're moving more and more
toward a digital economy
um i actually think this story is
important because
you know as you were saying there's
excitement at some of these conferences
and there's
you know it is exciting as we move
toward a digital economy and the key
players that are bringing us there
are important whether they want to be in
the open or not um
i would even encourage anyone who wants
to stay completely anonymous but they
still want their
theories methodology narratives and
um you know way of looking at the world
known
i would still think that would be worth
publishing um because it's shaping the
world around us right now
and as for you know we talked a little
bit
you know off the record about the
aftermath
um homeland security investigated
open an investigation as my story was
coming out
i of course got lots of email but i got
email from one group in particular that
have
real information to share and i do hope
to write a follow-up story
that provides a lot more information
surrounding
you know what i reported initially but
there is so much more
and it isn't you know it isn't specific
to just dorian and i think we all knew
that
you know we all it was not satisfying to
just focus on dorian
there is definitely more and i hope very
much to be able to share that
i also feel like i want to respect the
privacy and feelings of some of the
people who've talked to me
so you know i hope to be able to do that
and because i'm a journalist
i'm gonna keep trying to do that um i
feel i have a duty especially after the
first story
to do it yeah and then you've got a very
unique perspective
because um going through all of the work
and conversations that you did for the
newsweek story and then kind of
living through the aftermath of it and
the scrutiny
uh and then uh you know when we
connected it was because you
recently wrote a piece an institutional
investor about kind of crypto on wall
street
and so you know two very different types
of stories same assets
right in terms of uh tracking down
satoshi nakamoto
and then talking now about kind of wall
street hedge funds um
becoming very interested in this so
maybe tell us a little bit about the
institutional investor story and kind of
what you found there as you looked at uh
crypto on wall street yeah and you know
it's all related
because you have when i look at this
broadly
you have the finance piece obviously you
have
the government piece you know whether
it's regulation
or the intelligence side of things um
and then you have the people using it
right the consumers or the um
the people who are really into bitcoin
and want to be completely unbanked
you know that sort of thing so you have
sort of these three i
look at it as these three big pieces
which is kind of like bitcoin fans
the you know straight lace wall street
people were the digital finance
you know wonks who are working on the
infrastructure and then
this kind of regulatory intelligence
government piece
and you know they all really do come
together
and for people who want to know you know
is there a piece of u.s
intelligence in this yes there is yes
there is
there's not it's not um it's not a
mystery that that would be the case
based on the technology that created
bitcoin a lot of it harks
to things that were being used by our
intelligence communities
so um you know how that turned into an
invention and then that turned into
wall street seeing possibilities and
then the government saying oh god we're
clearly moving toward a digital economy
and we need to figure out how to get
around this
you know not around it but get our get
our hands around it so we can figure out
how to regulate it
have some law based sense of what's
going on
and so this story really delves into
like those different pressure points
you know how wall street's getting much
more excited uh especially with
the dollar not looking so great these
days
you know they're not that many places to
flee the system
you know the system is pretty big now
and but you have bitcoin and it's a way
to flee the system
um it was one that was seen as fringe
for so long but now you have these very
heavy duty big players on raw street who
are saying
i need to flee the dollar and
anything denominated in it that might
hurt me or anything that might be
affected by this pandemic
um and actually you know devalue my
investments
you know and bitcoin is a very very good
place to go for some of those people
um but you also have the regulators in
washington i talked to many lawyers who
and people on the regulatory side who
are still very down on bitcoin
um one theory right lawyer very very
experienced
who works with them the sec said to me
he said well all they're doing is
swapping it for something else
so so what there's no inherent thing you
know it's not like a barrel of oil it's
not like a piece of paper that
represents a barrel of oil
it's just a store of value that you can
swap for another store of value and
that's all
and i mean that's a very simplistic way
of looking at it as we know
um but there's still a real disconnect
and so this story was really talking
about the genuine disconnect between
well-meaning people
who want to see a great digital economy
um but are afraid about what will change
do what
what kind of risk will come with the
change and at the same time as you know
we have venezuela china and iran
who love the idea of being at the
forefront of a digital economy with
copycat coins that allow them to go
completely outside the u.s banking
system
we've been controlling a lot of these
countries and then using
um our dollar to
attack opponents when diplomacy or
or actual war doesn't work well we can
hit their bank accounts because so much
is denominated at least in part in the
us dollar
so when you talk about asymmetrical
warfare the treasury department can
quickly
come after people just through their
money and that can be very effective
um so if we're going to change money
that changes our national security as
well
yeah and i think what's um you know kind
of eye-opening about this
is that when you look at those other
countries like the game theory here's
like one of the number one questions i
always get from people who are first
learning about it
is they say something to the effect of
why can't the government just ban it or
why won't the government ban it and i
actually think that
part of it is there are a lot of other
countries out there that
want to see the u.s dollar system
maybe not fall but just they don't want
to be on it right and so if all of a
sudden there's a
decentralized digital currency that they
know the u.s is you know bearish on or
banning
ownership of for citizens i actually
think like that might serve as a magnet
for them to all go adopted
right and kind of move to that system
and so the game theory almost prevents
governments from stepping in and banning
it is that kind of your take given the
the kind of work that you've done
so you probably saw in my article where
jamie dimon
of jpmorgan had said you know they'll
ban it they're not going to
tolerate an alternative currency for
long
again naive because as soon as there is
one and it's thriving
it's a great haven not just for
investors trying to flee the dollar
but criminals and money launderers and
terrorists trying to flee the dollars so
that they can
that they can do a tax without needing
to rely on the dollar or anything
related to the us banking system so of
course
the u.s could have just banned it and
stuck their head in the stand i think
you know any of us who weren't born
yesterday of course they probably would
have tried to do so but
they can't do so when everyone else is
now adapting it or moving toward it
the only choice is to be at the
forefront of it which is part of the
arguing that's going on now in
washington is
how do we not fall behind but how do we
not undermine our own
currency does this hurt our sovereignty
does it hurt our national security do we
understand the risks
but we also if we if we if we take too
long
someone else will develop a giant
financial system
around us and be participating in it and
we'll
we won't even be in that position to
lead it um so you know
it is a threat but it's not a threat we
can't
deal with you know we're we are
hopefully
um all evidence to the contrary lately
uh
we're hopefully gonna try to stay at the
forefront of other countries in the
world when it comes to our
banking system you know our banking
system is needing a disruption we know
this
um it's probably more overdue than any
other sector and i've heard people
saying this now for well over a decade
so it's time yeah and it feels like
uh the adoption by wall street
specifically not only one
uh further cements kind of bitcoin's
place and crypto
currencies place in the global system um
but two is uh you see more and more
folks so whether it's paul tudor jones
even you know the jp morgan's uh now
kind of coming in
and realizing hey we have to do
something here it really does
feel like we're at a point where uh it's
no longer the taboo subject of wall
street
it's now okay what are we going to do
about it and it feels like that was kind
of
one of the main takeaways i got when i
read the article that you wrote was just
like
this is here and they know that now it's
here and it's not going to go away
and you know we honestly our
intelligence community already knows
that and has known it for some time
um that's why i kind of wrote a little
bit about that in the story
about you know the the working
assumption is that we will be fully
moved to a digital economy by 2040
you know and i think that might even be
i mean it sounds like aggressive but it
probably isn't very aggressive when you
really think about it
so um they're already putting pieces in
place quietly
to try to make sure that they're ahead
of the game um
and at the same time wall street's
caught on so i i think the cat is too
much out of the bag now
you know somebody might hear this
interview and say oh she's such a
bitcoin fan
i'm just being practical um i am
an economics fan but i just think that
at this point it's clear where we're
going and
um there are people who are going to
sort of not feel comfortable
i think i think it's much fairer to say
i don't feel comfortable if you're
someone who's still skeptical
because there is certainly all sorts of
risks we've already addressed
so those are real it's okay to not be
comfortable but that doesn't mean we can
bear your head in the sand we're
probably gonna have to figure it out
and wall street wall street knows that
too and i think one of the things that
is um is really uh
when you unpack a critic's
kind of uh argument there's the like
what i'll call the the really surface
level
uh things like you know money's a belief
system nobody believes in this or
there's no commodity backing you know
all those types of things that are
pretty easy at this point to disprove
and
and i think the bitcoin community and
even people on wall street now kind of
move past those types of arguments
and what you get to at the heart of it
is there is a subset of the population
who just believes there's no way this
can happen
right and they can't articulate why or
how
but it's just the belief that like no
way and i
and it took me a while to get to this
point or to understand that but once i
it like
got my head i was like these people have
lived their entire life
in one you know paradigm of the world
and they don't think that there could be
a transition to another and so like
that's actually like a
fair belief i don't believe it's
accurate but like i now understand
why there's such a mental block i think
for some people to kind of
change their mind or or get over that
home because it's not a logical
you're like you're not going to walk in
and have a logical argument and all of a
sudden then be like
oh of course this makes a ton of sense
right instead what you're going to get
is you're going to get
uh people who just eventually have to
realize like yes
transition is possible right yeah i mean
it's true there's no reason to think
this is going to be an easy transition
our infrastructure our laws everything
isn't really set up for this
you know that's why you saw you know the
cc's repeatedly saying like we're not
going to rewrite our rules for this you
know
our rules don't really match what's
going on here and you know it was not
created to match sec rules it wasn't
created
to fit in with existing infrastructures
that wasn't the point
uh the point was in fact to move away
from them
um and i i think the sdcc can keep
arguing it's not going to change the
rules to fit it but i think they're
going to be forced to eventually
um because it's where we're headed you
know the momentum is really behind
this and it's not necessarily only
bitcoin as we all know you know
many other ways to to participate in the
digital economy
yeah um and before we move on from kind
of bitcoin crypto like
what what are the things that don't make
it into that story right in terms of as
you have conversations on wall street
like what were made
your like takeaways in terms of how many
of these hedge fund managers
and other players on wall street are
kind of thinking about all of this
yeah so there was so much in this story
we had to cut it down like several times
um i mean there was a lot my editor was
like
was like there's just too much stuff in
here
um and i always want to say so much more
than i can so
it's you know i got to tell you i know
that nobody is going to cry for a
journalist
especially with the enemy of the people
and all that going on right now but like
it really is hard when you have like an
embarrassment of riches
that you just want to like let somebody
download i mean i'm looking forward to
that day where we all have chips in us
and i can just like download stuff to
somebody else
that would be really great um but right
now you know you just have to fit it
into some kind of coherent story
um and thanks for asking about like what
ended up in the cutting room floor
because quite a bit
um i really found interesting talking to
people who are trading
offshore on these exchanges that nobody
really knows or understands and i
thought it was sort of important to
include
um something about that and i may write
about it some more
but the the few things that i loved were
some of the weird offshore things that
people have to explore the hard way
right like the same way you explore a
new land you just have to jump in
and see what happens um one of the
people i talked to
said that as their firm was trading in
these different markets
that they would try to contact whatever
this exchange was you know whether it
was
in like malta or gibraltar or you know i
think there was
one place that had like oh like over a
dozen
like very highly trafficked exchanges um
slovenia i think
um and you know if you google bitcoin
and slovenia
you're like oh wow it's like all bitcoin
you know um they they basically said
they would try to find out if they could
find a real person
with a real name uh behind
any exchange we're going to trade on and
so the risk management side and the
compliance side is really tricky
and one person said to me we don't even
care
what we do is we just we do it the way
you first tried paypal or we do it the
way
you buy something on ebay that's used
and you don't really know what you're
gonna get we just like try it once
if it goes okay we do it again
you know and we build trust from there
um
so i love the concept of like this kind
of like you know
explorer of digital currencies trying to
figure out like
what things work for you you know one
one traitor we really respect
um danny masters i don't know if you
know him
but danny masters was was saying um
i believe he was the one who said some
of the weirder exchanges are where you
can make the most money
and i don't know if that's true because
one of the rules of journalism is you
don't
you don't uh have you can't invest in
something you're writing about
because that's then you're not an
objective person anymore
so i can't go buy a ton of bitcoin i've
obviously bought it to see how it works
but um as i told you i've only ever
owned five pounds sterling in my life of
bitcoin
because you have to stay outside of the
topic you're writing about but he was
telling me
that some of these exchanges are
phenomenal um
i also found the products being created
and some of the innovations
i really feel like i need to do like a
top 20 every year
of like top 20 innovations globally in
this
in this area because they're so cool
and they're much more
nuanced often than what you're going to
find in an ordinary u.s
standardized market um and so i would
love to start doing something like
maybe you and i should talk about that
but um i would love to do
like a top 20 innovations in this area a
year
you know so people because we can't stay
on top of them all there's just so many
you need someone to look at them all and
kind of create it for you
so those are the things that yeah didn't
they get
and what's interesting too is um so you
take a danny masters right you take some
of these folks that you interviewed
and uh these people are no slouches when
it comes to understanding financial
infrastructure to understanding trading
to understanding markets and assets
like they are some of the best and most
experienced
and most successful in the traditional
markets and so when they come in and
they say something like
oh some of these exchanges are pretty
good you know pretty good
uh in their eyes is actually usually
really good in the eyes of kind of the
average person right which i think is
always fascinating that
um you know they're making a comparison
usually not to kind of the bottom of the
bucket of crypto infrastructure
they're actually usually comparing it to
like the things that they're used to
using in the traditional world right
yeah absolutely i mean danny came from
jp morgan he was head of energy training
um uh he he was somebody actually who
was very helpful in my first book about
the oil market
um i've known him since i was in my
early 20s which is amazing i'm 44 now
um and yeah he i mean he's kind of seen
it all
um the nice thing about somebody like
danny is
he doesn't get hysterical but i mean he
is british so you know
there's that that kind of groundedness
that he brings to things but
he doesn't get hysterical about anything
very easily and so
you have to sit up and listen when danny
says something because he will often
you know come out and say i've looked at
this and this is what i think
and it's definitely worth considering
you know he's he's a source i
i definitely have frequently talked to
when
you're screaming from all corners and
then you need to talk to somebody who's
like the adult in the room
danny's really good at that and we do
need adults in the room
we i i do love this sort of super
exuberance
in so many parts of this market but we
really do need those sort of like
you know danny's not a b encounter but
we do need to be encounters and we do
need that
the people who are really going to be
skeptical and come in and roll up their
sleeves and figure out how to
make this work you know i know that a
lot of people don't think it should ever
be merged with our financial system but
i think
it's clear it's gonna need to be and
it's going to be
um hopefully we can keep the spirit of
it
you know where it needs to be where it's
more inclusive and egalitarian
you talk to me a lot about wealth um
we're talking about wealth equality and
the wealth gap
and in the beginning of the interview
and you know if i can speak to those who
have
come from an insider perspective about
bitcoin and the genesis of bitcoin
it's very much about egalitarianism and
not about being popular not about being
sexy
but about a more equal world for all and
i hope that it doesn't get moved into
something that's
that's that doesn't embrace that yeah
and i think that this
was um one of the uh inflection points
for me mentally
when i started to really uh think more
critically and understand
uh i'm trying to get out of this thing
go ahead do you want to close it yeah
yeah go ahead
so you're perfectly fine if you want to
close it more go ahead
you're all good i think we're good good
okay perfect
and we can just edit that part out um so
the
the inflection point for me mentally was
around this idea of
uh inflation is one of the greatest
causes of wealth inequality
and the rich get richer the poor get
poorer the perfect example is what we've
seen
through this global pandemic where you
know basically billionaires in the
united states have made
half a trillion dollars and 50 plus
million people lost their jobs
and again i don't think that's actually
the billionaire's fault nor do i think
it's the
average citizen's fault right it's a a
feature of the system
and not a bug of the system right and so
part of i think this uh egalitarianism
or um or this view of bitcoin is
if you can actually return back to sound
money
you can drive a much more equitable
world right you can get back to
a maybe not a full um kind of collapse
of that wealth inequality gap but at
least a much smaller
one and when people hear that i think
that's like
a whoa and they understand it it starts
to have a much bigger meaning than just
what's the us dollar value of this asset
right and it sounds like you spent a lot
of time kind of thinking about wealth
inequality so maybe
just kind of give us your overview of
the wealth and equality landscape
uh people probably don't know this but
you were actually nominated for an award
that
you on some of the work you did around
wealth inequality so i feel like you've
got way more information than anyone
else who's come on this
podcast can uh can share yeah i didn't
know we're gonna be talking about this
but i'm glad we are
um yeah i was i was part of a group of
stories that were nominated for the
national magazine award
um and it was on wealth inequality
uh i just felt i was so tired of hearing
about how unequal everything is we know
it's unequal
so my question was you know i said to my
editor i want to find the most equal
place
like where is the most equal place in
the country
um because we were doing all these
roundups of the least equal places right
and
it wasn't necessarily very you know okay
what are you gonna do with that
you know so i am i
i decided to just look at all the big
you know cities big and small across the
country there's a measurement called the
ginny coefficient which basically looks
at
the disparity between the wealthiest and
the forest in every community
and i found a place called ogden utah
which is still a town i'm extremely fond
of you know and i was
researching it from uh from over here on
the east coast and i went online
and it just looked like a phenomenal
town but of course my big question was
was if i fly there is it going to look
as good and
also are they just all equally poor
which is you know we wanted the most
equal but we also wanted the most like
doing well and equal so you know it
can't be all equally rich or all equally
poor because that's not really the point
the point is like who has a thriving
middle class
with a really reasonable genetic
coefficient and so
i flew out there and it turned out i
mean it couldn't have been better um
i was lucky i probably should have found
like a weird community that just
happens to have you know this part
working for it
um it turned out that this town had been
really doing badly
for a decade prior and
had fell into squabbling over what to do
as they declined you know when people
moved out
and one day somebody told me one day the
anchor store at the mall
pulled out and then within no time
everyone pulled out of that mall and
think of one of these giant strip malls
in the center of your town
they said the entire thing closed down
and was just filled with homeless people
within like
not too long and became this horrible
dangerous eyesore and
you know that was when the town was like
oh no what are we going to do
you know what's going to happen to us um
and they got together and started doing
all these amazing projects
and they did the right thing by not just
the community but
they started seeding small businesses um
which i found fascinating because a lot
of small businesses have to really
scrape for money
ogden was seeding something between like
eight and 12
small businesses every year with just
here's some cash
go for it um they did do screening
but they really just were trying to
create jobs and
business again and some level of
prosperity
and if you look at the statistics it's
small businesses that create the most
jobs in the united states
right so if you're not seating small
businesses you're not seating jobs
and this um economic development office
in the town i talked to them at length
and they
they told me after years of seeding
these businesses and and slowly the town
came back and by the time i got there it
was doing great
um the head of economic development when
we were driving through the town and
showing me all the businesses
um i said by now you probably have a
feeling for who's going to succeed and
fail right
and he goes no idea no idea
he said one of the most popular places
um it's a pizza place but now it's huge
like with tourists from everywhere and
people coming off the ski slopes
he said it was like two pot smoking
hippies who didn't know how to put a
business plan together
he said but now look at them you know so
it was
interesting to me that this idea of oh i
know what a good business is and i don't
know i i don't think you are and i think
you are you know i
he admitted he had no idea and that it
was more about
rolling the dice repeatedly because each
business that makes it pays into the tax
base again and then they would take that
money to see the next round of
businesses
and they were creating middle-class
housing very specifically focused on
middle-class housing because that's
where you get the most consumers and you
have the most um
you know people going to jobs needing
jobs kids going to the schools
you have a lot of participation in a
middle class i live in a community here
in vermont that has no meat in the
sandwich
it's like bread we have very wealthy we
have very poor
and then there's really no room for the
middle class and like this town
figured it out and so i really think
that
if we can look at the success stories we
can start to figure out like how to
heal our communities um this particular
economic development director i hate to
rave so much about it but it was so
impressive
they had actually focused on creating a
downtown with an amphitheater and bike
paths
and they purified the river and they
they made it so that all traffic was
being driven downtown on a regular basis
and they were putting on events
regularly so there was constant
engagement
and the housing they were building was
emanating out from downtown
so it was like if we can figure like
there's this core
they were like growing it out from there
and so it just was only becoming a
bigger point of thriving
um and they were making it very walkable
very bikable
which is like what we'd all live in our
towns yeah
it's so fascinating to hear how
they make a specific decision to go
and help small businesses and then that
ends up leading to
kind of value creation right and value
creation can be measured in many
different ways from economic
to just kind of quality of life gd code
fish and all this stuff
but that one decision seems to have kind
of a ripple
impact across the uh the entire local
economy right
yeah and they were really big on doing
private public partnerships as we know
those
they started being so successful that
people would come to them as soon as
they announced working on something
because they knew
that oh they're so good at this now like
we'll be associated with a success story
even if we only contribute a little bit
so at that point they've become a magnet
for people who wanted to be a part of
this story because they'd want to you
know if you're part of a success story
there's one more thing you can't brag
about
so at a certain point the town was kind
of creating prestige markers in what it
was doing
and i just i always talk about how you
can model prosperity
people think it's not possible it is
absolutely possible and you don't have
to start with that much but you do have
to believe
that was that was sort of what i learned
from ogden is it possible to take that
model and extrapolate it out
implement it nationally or is it only
possible in kind of a local economy in
your opinion
i think it starts with the local piece
because each economy has certain things
it can offer
like um i live in brattleboro vermont
right now especially with the pandemic
and you know we have rivers we have ski
slopes nearby
we have a beautiful downtown that
everyone's very precious about like no
chain stores are allowed it's all these
you know mom-and-pop shops and
you know there's all this really nice um
there's a beautiful arts community
there's pretty much every kind of
you know musician we have a circus
school that's part of cirque du soleil
here
like it's a pretty wild place for the
arts um
so each town has like kind of what it
offers
and you want to lean in to like what do
you offer the great outdoors do you
offer the arts do you offer
you know if you're over on the west
coast maybe it's a tech um
appeal that you can create but um i
think it starts with local but then you
can start knitting those things together
right like one of the things i found
brilliant about this model
or an ogden was they started looking at
what neighboring communities were doing
so that they could
augment what they were doing but also
start pulling in
like and knitting together what they
were doing with these other communities
um especially by the way with the poor
um anybody was impoverished
they didn't want one of the things you
struggle with when you're dealing with
impoverished
parts of your community is if you give
too much
then you become a magnet and everybody
comes to you so what they were doing was
creating kind of um
contacts with the neighboring
communities like we'll offer this if you
offer that
and that way like we have a distribution
of assistance for people so it's not
like only one
it's not like elephants all getting into
a rowboat so that one town sinks
and so a lot of the modeling is really
important when it comes to
you know you can extend it obviously
nationally
but i think everybody has to be on board
with a certain amount of sharing
a certain amount of collaboration to do
it
yeah no it is um it's one of these
things where when you see it work
in a small community you want to try to
bring it nationally right but maybe the
magic is that it works in a small
community
uh another topic that uh you really care
deeply about and
i think you're actually working on
another book is uh around child abuse
uh maybe tell us a little bit kind of
where did uh did your interest and
intrigue
in that topic uh come from and then kind
of some of the work that you've done
there
yeah so while i was working i it sounds
like i'm involved in a lot of really odd
things right
i mean if i was watching this for the
first time i would be like
wait a minute so she covers oil but
bitcoin and then wealth
inequality and oh child abuse you know
it just seems pretty random you just
we're going to line those up on a board
um but each one kind of is iterative
uh while i was working in finance and i
was
covering um wall street and also when i
was living in london england
writing about finance over there a lot
of a lot about hedge funds
one of my hedge funds um actually danny
masters hedge fund went to this island
called jersey which is off the coast of
france and
i was already researching jersey when he
moved there
but i just found it interesting that
hedge funds were increasingly going over
there
and uh i was vacationing sometimes in
jersey to see friends
um jersey is the old jersey to new
jersey we won't get into the history and
everything but
it is a pretty amazing history um
uh it is where jersey cows come from
jersey potatoes when you hear about
jersey cream
it's all from this tiny island off the
coast of france it's about
it's about 12 miles off the coast of
france and it's a peculiar possession of
the british crown
and when they were making uh when they
were creating the european union
they basically created a carve out
that included this island as a tax
shelter so it doesn't really have to
follow the eu rules
and for a long time it became this kind
of prime place for the british to
shelter their money and people in the
middle east and
has a pretty big european following as
well
um and the island really became this
very powerful place with about two
trillion dollars
of tax shelter money even though it's a
tiny island
so i became very interested in this
place and i constantly heard rumors when
i was visiting the island
about the masons on the island and the
church
and these you know everyone to talk
about it like there were these cabals
and i just had never really heard
anything quite like that i grew up in
the boston area right we all know about
the scandals of the church
but it never had a cabal-like feeling
the way i was getting from the island
when i'd go there it was very
hush-hush you know in boston growing up
like
the church scandals were pretty wide
open everybody knew they were happening
but on the island of jersey like
people would whisper and sometimes they
wouldn't want to talk about it if we
were in public like they'd be like i'll
tell you more but we have to meet at the
hotel or you know and
i just thought for such a small
community for so many secrets to be
abounding
that uh it would it it intrigued me
um and so i started looking more into it
after the asylum
after the asylum during the time that i
was at my desk writing the asylum there
was a very big scandal on the island
involving one of the children's homes
which we would consider an orphanage
um in the uk that's not a word they like
to use
um has a lot of negative connotations
that they call the children's home
and they did a dig under an abandoned
children's home that closed in the 80s
there had been all these horrible
stories about what had happened there
powerful people on the island involved
and they had found children's remains
and then all of a sudden the police
officers were being
harassed targeted threatened the head of
police was suspended like
over and over again by the island's
authorities even though it wasn't clear
why they were suspending him they'd
always come up with a weird reason like
like oh he spent too much on the
investigation
or you know but they told him to like
leave no stone unturned so the whole
thing was strange
and watching it from the u.s i was like
this is bad
this is i've never seen police officers
not allowed to investigate
like this before um even as a global
journalist you don't usually see that
um except in you know maybe in africa
sometimes
but not in like a western democracy
right
so i was confused and and
packed my stuff and went over there for
the summer to investigate and all i
found was like more and more and more it
was like a bottomless pit
of just bad things and i thought oh god
i'm not going to be able to finish this
over the summer so i continued working
on it when i came back to the states
um and i kept traveling back and forth
very quietly and eventually
um i was interrogated
by the british authorities they actually
tried to block me from visiting the
island and reporting and they locked me
up in the basement of heathrow when i
was traveling
um interrogated me and then tried to ban
me from the country for two years
um the ban was overturned because it
wasn't legal
but um i received that was the first
time i'd received horrible threats this
was pre bitcoin
um and i would say that out of
everything i've been through my career
this was the hardest
because you know when someone locks you
up it's pretty scary um
if they haven't told you why you know i
wasn't being arrested
i just was put in a room and the door
was shut
and i wasn't able to contact anybody for
about a day
um so that is the next project i'm
working on
um what happened on this island the
people involved
how bad it was um this is still a
thriving tech shelter
um and it's still a place where every
single bank you can possibly name has an
office
like every single bank a to z has an
office in jersey because it's where
you can do really amazing deals um
offshore
um and outside of regulation and so
uh the work that you've done um
literally has spanned years on this
and uh you're writing a book about it is
the
uh is kind of the uh we know the topic
but it's like the angle of the book
flushed out yet
or not are you still working on that so
the hardest thing right and that the
hardest thing
in the world is to talk about abuse of
this level
and you know we use the word abuse very
generically you know
it's not a gen it shouldn't be a generic
term because what happened to the
children on this island was like i
recall
it up there with the crimes described in
the holocaust
like that level of psychological
horror um physical you know
horror and and just you know pitting
brothers and sisters against each other
and
small children who were best friends and
didn't have parents and against each
other it was very very sad
um and you know it's clear children died
the island certainly is not comfortable
acknowledging that but it's very obvious
that they did and
that the home only closed in the late
80s
right so a lot of people are still alive
to talk about it
and the home itself was occupied by the
nazis as a signal station during world
the war ii the island has a very rich
history of you know
very serious situations like the nazi
occupation
um so the people on the island are you
know
they are still recovering from what i
would call like a legacy
of some very scary experiences that are
in addition to the abuse that took place
with these children
so a lot of it's about the background of
the book
definitely involves the history but
um i really had to open my heart to this
island in order to understand it better
so at this point i feel very attached to
the people
and to the place and to tell a
compassionate story about how this
happened
going back to our earlier discussion on
how does corruption happen
how do people do horrible things and
maybe most importantly how do people who
who don't want horrible things to happen
end up being silenced
right how do people end up silenced who
would never want this to take place
um end up enabling it instead which is
sadly you know you could classify that
pretty high up next to the crimes
themselves
so i'm fascinated by this idea of how
democracy can break down
and we're watching it right now in our
own country you know a lot of the people
on the
islands talk about what's happening in
our country and
uh say you know look what was going on
with you you know and what can i say
you know we're all susceptible to
breakdowns of our system
um breakdowns of democracy and we're
sort of now living in this post-truth
world where the big question is
how do we define truth how do we define
facts how do we
report these things so this book seeks
to
really root everything in concrete facts
but to also explore what happens when
stories
can become so convoluted and so so
subject to debate
um what can take place and in the case
of this island the police were not able
to finish their investigation
and the islands filled in the basement
where they found the remains with cement
before anyone else could look
makes it hard to uh to get some facts
then um
yeah when it when will the uh the book
come out
um hopefully in a year or so this year
is a big writing year
um with the pandemic most writers will
tell you
it's a great year to do writing um but
because i can't travel to the island
very much because of all the
you know as the us is now being treated
like a leper colony
uh by the rest of the world so traveling
is tricky so i'm hoping
all the writing will be done this year
fingers crossed
very cool and and before i move to uh to
kind of wrap
up um where can people find you uh on
the internet or find
uh some of the password that you've done
either for uh for media
organizations or the books well right
now i'm redoing my website so the best
place to find me is just on twitter
which is that true theater underscore
well it's truth underscore eater
and so go to truth underscore eater
on twitter you can find me there or just
type my name leah mcgrath goodman
um my email and my contact information
is kind of all over the internet now so
you can also email me and
um linkedin works too all the usual
places
but uh yeah and i do have a book coming
out in november that's an auto uh
it's it's it's really not related to the
corruption investigations i do
but it's a biography of ariana
huffington from the huffington post and
that was just sort of
a fun project to do while i do some of
these more serious projects
but it's it's a good summer read and
that'll be coming out in november in the
us
can people pre-order that yet yeah you
can go to amazon pre-order
amazon and uh just search uh ariana
huffington i'm assuming
um arianna huffington and probably my
name because she has so many books
here's so many books or so yeah all
right then my last question before we
get into the rapid fire is where did the
twitter name truth eater come from what
is going on with that
oh my gosh i don't know i think it was
just whimsical at the time
i you know i didn't really know what
twitter was going to become
so i people will tell you you know
it's all odd because when we talk about
the bitcoin investigation in the bitcoin
project
that was i think everyone has a moment
in their lives that's
like a moment of truth where
their identity and how people see them
can end up in this like very difficult
standoff
and people who know me personally know
that i'm not only obsessed with truth
but i'm kind of that
that [ __ ] like who you know cool say
to a friend like but you are addicted to
drugs though
no or you know you know i say it out of
love but it is true even that sort of
thing so
um i'm very much like you know stay true
with compassion but don't not stay true
don't be part of that silent majority
always say what you're certain of and be
open
to changing facts um because
um you might have facts but there might
be new facts
that put old facts into a new context so
i'm kind of a stickler about all that
and maybe that's where true theater came
from i can't even
remember but you know whenever you're
confronted with anyone who thinks you
don't care about facts you know for me
that's deeply personally heartbreaking
um because i'm just that horrible person
who
even when it's convenient and in my best
interest to ignore facts
like i will cleave to them and
i often get into trouble because of it
but
um but i i can't help myself like i feel
like that's my religion i'm not a
religious person but i
i might be a little spiritual but i
definitely have a fact
based truth-based religion for myself
that's awesome
uh yeah i asked the same ask the same
two questions uh to wrap up and then
you're gonna get to ask me one two to
finish
uh the first is what is the most
important book that you've ever read
the most important book oh my god
that's brutal i didn't know about these
questions
that's so tough can i do question number
two first sure
uh it's more fun um aliens believer or
non-believer
total believer why um in fact i'm
reading a book that journalists were on
ufos
and all the government research where
she did like all the you know
retired kernels and all that stuff oh
because it's so self-centered for us to
think that there's
nothing out there i mean how can we
possibly think that
i mean i was talking to a trader over
lunch the other day
he he's extremely brilliant when it
comes to money but he's kind of
not very widely philosophical right and
he said
he said i was watching nova or you know
one of those old pbs shows
he's like and they said that there could
be an edge to the universe but there
also might not be an end
it might just go on forever and his eyes
just were like as big as dinner plates
and i was like yeah no i know i mean
didn't you deal with that in the second
grade when you asked your dad
and he was like no he's like it's
terrifying because
neither makes sense if it ends then what
is it a wall or
and he's like and if it doesn't end and
then he just kind of stared off into the
distance
i just thought it's true right i mean
like neither answer is very satisfying
um but we have to believe that there's
so much more than ourselves
i just don't think probabilistically
it's possible that there isn't
um but you are saying ufos are aliens
uh well so that's the the big debate
right is uh when i asked the question
some people
say well you know the ufos lead me to
believe that aliens are real some people
say the ufos are completely different
than aliens
everyone's got their own kind of
different analysis which is why i enjoy
asking the question
yeah i think i want to answer to aliens
in this case because
a ufo can just be a satellite that you
got wrong right
um and as far as the most important book
oh that is so
hard um i might have to go
with um a book that i recently
reread that i just think everyone should
read and it's so fabulous
it's called the executioner song um
what does that mean it's written it it
was
written in a very journalistic style
norman mailer
and it's about um
it's about a man who had killed
was he was a criminal and he ended up
being almost like a national phenomenon
he murdered um and ended up in jail but
might have done some of the best pr
campaigns before there were ever real
modern day pr campaigns um the nike
the nike uh just do it comes from him
right before he was executed he was like
let's do this or whatever nike ended up
adopting it much later
as just do it but um it's just such an
interesting story it goes so deep and i
love
anything that's journalistic and goes
really deep into people's lives
um so it's called the executioner song
highly recommend it
you'll totally get swallowed whole by it
um it's a big book so people are afraid
of big books
but i'm assuming most of your um most of
your people
are you know non-fiction lovers i'm i'm
also a fiction lover
but a lot of people on wall street are
and tech are non-fiction lovers but the
executioner song is something i highly
recommend
they'll read anything they're uh uh last
last night i uh i tweeted a photo of uh
the dao of capital
uh mark spitznagel and uh a bunch of
people like oh
i wouldn't bought it right now so i
think that at this point i could uh
maybe tweet even like a barney book or
something and then they go get it
um all right yeah there's way i have to
give you one more before
i'm being greedy um probably my very
favorite
is called the birth of the modern and i
believe it's by a man named paul johnson
it's called the birth of the modern and
it is
all about the laying of the foundations
of modern society and it spans
everything from science to art to music
and it's it basically is this 15-year
span between 1815 and 1830 when
you might be an astronomer and a
composer and
you know a banker right you know when
people these renaissance men that did
everything
um but it also gets into like the road
building and the bridge building and how
many people died while building
skyscrapers and
it's just so fascinating um it goes
really you'll end up buying a bunch of
other books while you read it because it
goes so deep into different people's
lives
um it's like a rosetta stone for what is
today's modern world but goes it starts
really in the 1800s and
i mean it talks about the founding of
this country and the most
graphic terms heartbreaking terms and
you realize that we were just
insanely violent you know uh the stuff
we don't learn in history class
just how violent we were and i remember
reading about andrew jackson in this
book and how he slaughtered new orleans
all these native americans didn't really
have permission from the us government
but just went ahead and did it
and one baby lived and he adopted that
little boy
into his own family and raised my son um
but i mean the stories were just amazing
and unknown to me and
um really strongly recommend the birth
of the modern probably my favorite most
important book
that's a great suggestion uh you could
ask me one question to finish up what uh
what one question do you have
oh i want to hear your favorite book
favorite um
i don't just have one uh i would oh my
god you're
trying to make us have one
yeah most people actually end up giving
more than one um so
uh books that i think are important
um i kind of put them in categories so
like finance wise i always and people
who listen to have heard me say so many
times
there's three books that i read when i
was like 20 21 years old that were very
impactful so rich dad poor dad
richard spann and babylon and think and
grow rich and i literally read them like
sequentially right at a formative time
so like that was
um always kind of top of mind um
what uh jared diamond's uh gun sherman's
steel
is you know it sounds very similar like
the birth of the modern uh kind of
the history of the world and the humans
which i think is really interesting
uh i really liked um when is it uh when
breath becomes air
i think right it is uh yeah it's a good
one
uh the dao of capital is a good one um
and then let's see maybe one more wow
uh you know what book i actually really
enjoyed that um
that you'd probably be familiar with is
uh the book that uh steve schwartzman
wrote uh recently
uh whatever it takes i haven't read it
yet did you read it
yeah it's very good um so i've read
really
you're like is he a writer maybe i'm
sure so i don't know who wrote it but
it's
but it's definitely uh it's cool because
i think it
it has the perfect balance between being
entertaining
uh being informative in terms of like
here's what we did
and also uh sharing like the mindset and
perspective and kind of all of that so
some of these books are like you know if
you read um
i don't know like like a lot of the
executive type books are just
basically pr pitches but like if i had
to think so schwartzman's book was good
ken langone's book was good
uh sam zell's book was good ted turner's
book was good like there's a couple of
them that kind of are
informative entertaining and also share
that perspective
um so when i find those like they're
they're pretty rare and uh i'll try to
uh to share them with folks but
yeah if you're an extraordinary person
like hopefully your book is
somewhat extraordinary at the very very
least
well it's also like um you know take
shortsman like he's built such a massive
business
and been doing it for so long um so it's
funny to kind of see
uh the stories that he remembers like he
tells a story in the book
of um they open up blackstone
they run a big ad in the paper nobody
calls
uh they're like moving into a new office
on like park avenue or something and you
know they're like expecting everyone on
wall street to come
and do business with them nobody shows
up uh they get a knock on the door
and there's a guy uh in a motorcycle
jacket
and you know steve's like are you like
the food delivery dude like what are you
doing here
and the guy's like oh my sister said she
worked with you at your last company and
told me to come see you
and so uh he invites the guy in who's
literally got his motorcycle chained up
outside
uh and they sit on the floor because
there's no furniture yet and they just
talk about
investing and turns out that guy is sam
zell who they end up doing all these
deals with and then he later buys the
the big reap from him
and so it's like you hear that story and
you're just like
man you've done a lot of deals you've
done a lot of things in your life
but you remember sitting on the floor
with samso when you first opened you
know blackstone
and like it was important enough for you
to put in the book right so i think
that's like kind of the interesting
stuff that
uh just like what makes it in the book
versus what doesn't
um and so he's got stories like that
when he met jack welsh
at dinner when jack welsh was like a
associate somewhere or something you
know and he's just like yeah and
like jack welsh became jack welch i just
was friends with him when he was just
you know
jack and you're like wow okay
it's a really small world i mean it's
amazing how
it's amazing how one project i do have
some link with somebody i didn't expect
and
you know it really is a small world
especially when it comes to
people um circulating and the money tech
circles
it's very small um and it's just it's
really funny when you mentioned
blackstone i just remembered i did a
story
in the journal about blackstone doing
some deal
and the night editor after passed it in
you know when you do a spell check and
you hit ignore through the spell check
they hit change through the entire spell
check
and so blackstone was turned into
bloodstone
for the entire story and went into print
in the wall street journal as bloodstone
and there was somebody named in the
story who had done the deal and his last
name was like
an our last name but somehow you know
how the wall street journal would use
these
honorifics like mr so and so you know
they'd use the last name but with a
mister
yes in front of it somehow the our last
name had been turned into
raccoon and so throughout the story it
was like mr raccoon said
like the whole thing was a mess and it
went to print
and you can imagine like blackstone
calls me in the morning and they're like
what is this
and they didn't even know what to say
because they were like we want a
correction but
we don't even know what to do because
it's such a mess because somebody had
changed all these words
and uh in the end we all just kind of
laughed like they were angry
and then we all just had to laugh and
and somebody called me back from black
spin on a stone and said
they were like i think bloodstone might
even be a better name
well the people competing with them
probably think so for sure
yeah anyway um thank you so much this
was very enjoyable
and uh i i want to urge people um we're
almost that limit
but i want to urge people um if they do
have real questions or things they want
to share
about anything that i'm working on
whether it's the child abuse
investigation on the
on the island of jersey whether it's um
bitcoin whether it's their thoughts or
information that they think would be
helpful or wealth inequality
oil market any of those things anything
related to trading and money
attack i'm always very interested and um
i you know i really appreciate having
the time to chat with you
absolutely listen you did a fantastic
job thank you so much for uh for taking
the time to do this and we'll have to do
it again in the future
great i'll talk to you soon take care